throughout this week we've been talking
qualitatively about the feeling that joe
biden's presidency has turned around
we've listed the different
accomplishments over the last two three
months and particularly over the last
three to four weeks but we didn't yet
have anything quantitative to answer the
question
is there really a turnaround happening
is joe biden's approval actually
increasing and the reason we care about
that is not so much as a curiosity
although it's interesting to see a
president have such a low approval
rating for a while and then see it
recover because 10 what tends to happen
during presidencies is there's an
erosion of approval over time
um
what is interesting about it is its
impact on the november midterms which
are now just roughly
nine weeks or so away by very very very
rough estimate looking at the calendar
if indeed joe biden's approval rating
continues to increase at the rate at
which it has over the last 10 days
it is all of a sudden looking very bad
for republicans in november so the first
question is what are the numbers well
joe biden's approval rating has spiked
11 percent in a very short period of
time now for those who may or may not
understand the precision with which i am
speaking
11
increase is not an 11
point increase
the approval rating of joe biden
bottomed out at 37 and a half
right on july 21st and it has now gone
up to 41.6
that is of course not an increase of 11
percentage points but it is an 11
increase in one month that is
significant and if you see even
half or two-thirds of that increase
continue until november you're going to
have a quite popular joe biden
on the day of the midterm elections
because these midterms are in a sense
referenda
on those in power which in this case
includes a democrat in the white house
democrats controlling the senate
although barely and democrats
controlling the house the conventional
wisdom would be that would be very good
for democrats and you can tell that
biden is sort of reinvigorated in a
sense he is back on the campaign trail
and starting to
be visibly campaigning for democrats
running in november yesterday at a rally
against a trump allied
uh republican in maryland
he gave a uh quite good speech in which
he slammed the maga movement as
semi-fascism and i think that that's a
pretty good term i sometimes call it
wannabe fascism
uh wet dream fascism
um authoritarian uh uh uh
you know wishing whatever you want to
call it joe biden back out there and
listen these are just empirical
questions there was the feeling that
there was a turn around that turn around
is very much reflected this is and by
the way if you look
even though the number is still under 42
for biden's approval
the rate at which it increased is
significant and we have not seen that
during biden's presidency
uh so far it matches essentially the
quickest decline that we saw in august
of 2021 as republicans were slamming
biden for the pull out from afghanistan
and covet numbers were not looking good
this is as rapid an increase as we have
seen a decrease during the biden
presidency and we still have time but it
so far bodes very very well
completely opposite what is going on for
joe biden which has been very good
things are going disastrously for the
failed former president donald trump who
is desperate desperate to claim
innocence and try to get himself out of
all sorts of legal trouble uh and
potentially justify another presidential
run in 2024. donald trump had a historic
meltdown yesterday
on truth social declaring himself
innocent declaring himself innocent and
you have to see these posts just a sort
of diarrhea of the post donald trump
starting quote even though i am as
innocent as a person can be and despite
my campaign being spied on by the
radical left the fisa court being lied
to and defrauded and all of the many
hoaxes and scams that were illegally
placed on me by very sick and demented
people and without even mentioning the
many crimes of joe and hunter biden all
revealed in great detail in the laptop
from hell
it looks more and more like the fake
news media is pushing hard for the
sleaze to do something that should not
be done
that's an insane message
it is nuts that a former president typed
out that message and posted it publicly
there are probably 10 lies and
distortions in that short message
and by the way trump saying that he is
as innocent as anyone has ever been to
me suggests he's guilty now this isn't a
court of law i'm not suggesting trump be
denied due process this is the court of
common sense many things the more
strongly trump claims a the more likely
the opposite of a is likely to be true
uh and trump's kind of interesting in
that he's very direct in that sense many
politicians will equivocate and they'll
play semantics or they'll kind of
massage facts or distract and muddy the
waters when trump's guilty he'll just
come out and say i'm innocent
that's been the theme trump continuing
to post quote joe biden said he knew
nothing about the break-in of mar-a-lago
or the greatest political attack in the
history of the u.s does anybody really
believe this now there is no evidence
biden knew anything and of course it
wasn't a break-in it was a search
warrant signed by the attorney general
okayed by trump's own fbi director
appointee
and a judge signed off on it so again
all lies trump continuing quote the
radical left democrat prosecutors are
illegally trying to circumvent for
purely political gain the presidential
records act under which i have done
absolutely nothing wrong it cannot be
circumvented for me or any other
president they illegally raided my home
untrue and took things that should not
have been taken untrue they even broke
into my safe and unthinkable act well
the safe was listed in the search
warrant everything was perfectly legal
trump then resorting to just tweeting or
i'm sorry not tweeting trothing in all
caps presidential records act
trump then posting quote the justice
department and fbi are quote leaking at
levels never seen before
and i did nothing wrong i think trump's
brain is leaking at levels never seen
before
and then donald trump also putting out a
statement which is crazy which says joe
biden and the radical left democrats
have just orchestrated another election
enhancing money grab this time to the
tune of 300 billion dollars and just
like i predicted it's coming right out
of the pocket of the working class
americans who are struggling the most
crippling inflation unaffordable energy
prices and war
all things that should have never
happened but if that wasn't enough now
americans are bailing out college
administrators who fleeced students and
who opted for degrees there was no way
they could afford
america is a nation in decline and the
cliff into oblivion is within sight stop
voting for democrats make america great
again amis
very inspirational message from donald
trump it is not normal for anybody
it when your neighbor flips out on
social media like this it's cause for
alarm
this is a failed former president doing
it and it's incredibly humiliating
jared kushner donald trump's son-in-law
husband of ivanka appeared on fox news
he was asked about these documents that
donald trump stole and kept in his house
and jared kushner played about as dumb
as i've seen anybody play this this
really takes some skill to play this
dumb
leading political opponent is very
serious it's a very serious thing i
think that americans on both sides of
the political aisle have some real
questions about what they did um there's
a
section in the book where you talk about
the zelinski transcript and you argued
let's get it out there let's just put it
out there so are you arguing right now
to your former boss and father-in-law
you know put out what these documents
are put out what they're about in these
in these presidential documents tell
everybody what's in there yeah well i i
don't know whether he knows what's in
the boxes or not again these were boxes
that were in storage if you know anyone
knows donald trump knows he keeps a ton
of stuff they're always in boxes all
over the place and you know who knows if
there were things that he did
intentionally unintentionally yeah he
not only might he not know what was
there those things maybe were
unintentionally there now here comes the
it's already getting it's stretching
credulity but then it gets really weird
there's reports i've read that the gsa
packed the boxes so like i said i think
that right now what we want to know is
what's in the affidavit i think that's
the transparency we should get to but i
do think president trump was probably
one of the most transparent presidents
that we've had in a very long time now
of course that's completely untrue
missing call logs from january 6th all
sorts of obfuscation people missing from
white house visitor logs arguably again
democrats are going to do voter fraud
what they meant was we're going to try
to steal an election trump was the most
transparent really trump was the least
transparent and he sat for interviews
all the time he was always asking
answering questions from the press you
knew what he thought of at 12 o'clock at
night when he would tweet you know what
he thought at six in the morning when he
would tweet yeah and so i know he
definitely is is often on the side of
transparency have you asked him you know
if he knows what's in there or if he
went through them or if he intentionally
kept something back when the fbi when
the lawyers said that they had already
taken out everything that was classified
i haven't asked him that but i i have
been with him since then and he hasn't
uh seemed too concerned about it
[Laughter]
right
one of the
as they love to say
an unprecedented situation in
presidential history where a search
warrant is served the president's home
because of the documents he stole
jared acknowledges he's hung out with uh
trump since
but they just haven't talked about this
it just didn't come up if you can
believe that okay um
and martha mccallum okay okay i'm just
accepting it martha mccallum should be
ashamed
jared kushner should be ashamed but
again
this is happening on a network fox news
where they just believe stuff they
believe what they're told they don't sit
and think
you know these aren't really tough
questions and there's no follow-ups and
jared's explanation makes no sense no
they just go let's listen they just
they've met but jerry doesn't know he
hasn't talked to trump about it as he's
one of his closest advisors from the
entire presidency
it simply didn't come up they were
talking about golf and well done steak
and putting ketchup on steak that was
really the only thing they talked about
but on fox news the what the viewers
just accept it they go yep that's what
it was they talked about other things
this is so funny
radical and repugnant reactionary
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
started complaining about how student
loan forgiveness which joe biden is now
doing
is uh it's bad it's unfair that some
people don't have to pay back loans they
took i mean they took out a loan and now
they don't have to pay it back and it
turns out that marjorie taylor green
took out a nearly two hundred thousand
dollar ppp loan that was the money
uh made available to businesses in the
pandemic relief packages during the
trump and biden uh pandemic relief
packages and uh it was forgiven she
didn't have to pay it back isn't that
just the best listen to this here's
marjorie taylor green attacking the
biden student loan debt relief that's
why they're the party where you don't
have to pay back loans that's why
they're the party that is just ripping
our country apart and joe biden is wrong
he can't break the law and just forgive
everyone's student loan debt it just
doesn't work that way right the
democrats are the party where you don't
have to pay back loans and then we find
out
that the marjorie taylor green and
husband business taylor commercial
received a loan for a hundred and eighty
two thousand dollars
and they had a hundred and eighty three
thousand dollars forgiven
why is the amount forgiven more than the
loan amount well they also had accrued
interest for given isn't that nice that
loan was reportedly for employee wages
of course as with any of the there's so
much ppp fraud the irs is investigating
generally we don't have any reason to
believe they're specifically
investigating the marjorie taylor green
loan but how much of that money
in theory for employee wages actually
went to marjory taylor green's employees
that's a very very good question and by
the way when she says it's the democrats
who are the party of not paying back
debts she supported trump trump who
often didn't pay debts often didn't pay
people that he owed money to now i do
want to mention
there is some consistency here
i have to sort of concede
it's pretty obvious hypocrisy but
there's one way you can interpret this
in which marjorie taylor green is being
consistent
she's about compassion for businesses
when it comes to finances
but not for individuals and in that
sense it's coherent with her philosophy
to the extent we can call it a
philosophy that she's mad about
individuals not having to pay back loans
but she's fine with businesses not
having to pay them back even when it's
all a complete sham what a lot of these
businesses did with the ppp money but
there it is marjorie taylor green a
hypocrite a wednesday august 31st
6 p.m eastern we are doing a members
only town hall it will be broadcast live
to everyone but only our existing
members
will be invited to participate in this
one and chat with me
we will be streaming it on youtube
twitch and facebook but if you want to
participate you do it via our discord at
davidpakman.com discord and of course to
be invited you must be a member at
joinpackman.com i'll remind you about it
next week
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported program you can sign
up at join pacman.com you will of course
get instant access to the world famous
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
thank you alex jones hates it we love it
and you also get a commercial free audio
and video stream of the show every
single day when you sign up at
joinpakman.com let's now speak to the
most important people
involved with the david pakman show
which are the viewers without the
viewers i'm a guy in a room with a
microphone and it's sad and it's
disappointing so we take calls via
discord at
davidpakman.com
discord and today we're going to start
with jonah in las vegas jonah welcome to
the program what's on your mind
hey david just wanted to know your
thoughts on the nevada senate race um
that is coming up i'm from there so just
interested to hear your thoughts i
haven't been following it to be honest
what's going on
uh the republican was trump's number one
big lie sort of conspirator in the state
um he was attorney general in 2018. oh
adam
that's right yeah and it's one of the
closest senate races by the polls by the
metrics by professionals whatever yeah
what i'm seeing is that
uh catherine cortez masto
um has overtaken laxalt in the latest
polls even though he had been leading is
that correct
uh it's been back and forth throughout
the cycle but
um
yeah regardless it's gonna be
incredibly close i think biden won by
two percent and she in her initial
election also won by two percent yeah
and the polling actually seems
controversial because there's only two
polls from august one has cortez masto
up seven and one has adam laxalt up
three i am not a fan of adam laxalt i
think he's absolutely horrifying uh and
i support cortez masto there and i think
that's an important race for people to
follow and get involved with you can
phone bank uh we we don't want to give
that one to laxalt
definitely
all right my otherwise vegas is good
yeah i mean
the uh it was really hit very hard by
covid but um
with the service industry but yeah
it's straight back well thanks jonah
great to speak to you you too all right
there is jonah from vegas with a
reminder about a very very important
race that's for sure
let's go next to guy from killeen texas
sky welcome
hi can you hear me yes i can
um so i had a question um that deals a
little bit more in like the
conspiratorial route um regarding like
trump's views on uh
like uh political views
okay he's never really ever made sense
to me as like a um
because i'm a democrat and whenever you
hear democrats speak about republicans
sometimes you will hear like then take
the most extreme views like on abortion
or something where um you know they say
the mother needs to be punished um and
you always say that like snl
should be put out of the job because a
lot of the things that republicans do
are just beyond parody at this point yes
so like what would make you believe like
if it ever came out in a book or
something after
trump's death or something that he was
like just secretly a democrat all this
time
just
living that caricature that they've set
out for republicans this entire time but
actually just was elected to the
presidency i don't so so here's my
thought
i don't think that so here's the thing
the idea of trump as a secret democrat
doesn't really make sense in the sense
that he genuinely did so much damage
like that would make more sense if trump
quote pretended to be a republican and
then became president and did a whole
bunch of stuff that democrats would do
but trump became president and then did
all sorts of horrible things that
democrats would never do so what i think
the scam is
is that trump was relatively apolitical
he based on where he grew up queen's and
manhattan he probably was a sort of
casual
center left guy his entire life and then
he just doesn't have the morals to say
i'm not going to pretend to be something
i'm not but he said i'm not going to win
the democratic primary i can only win
the republican primary he got some
traction with criticizing barack obama
and so
he was never a committed or real
republican in a sense it's just he's
developed this character for his
political presence out of expediency but
like the secret democrat idea in the way
you're proposing just doesn't really
make sense to me
okay yeah it was also part of that like
what you mentioned that like maybe he
was taking one for the team or something
like that and in a sense but okay that
makes sense
all right my friend thank you very much
for the call the audio i bumped the
audio up as much as i could and
hopefully uh we we were able to hear him
let's go next to
uh let's go to herb
from long island herb welcome
hey can you hear me yes i can
all right and thank you for taking my
call um
also for herb it's with a harder h oh
you say herb all right fair enough yeah
with a harder h that's all anyway uh i
do have a quick question for you um and
it's also about trump um
i know you've said before
when republicans
accuse people
of things it's actually an omission of
guilt right yeah i mean listen it
sometimes is it's not literally that way
i'm not saying deny them due process for
one but like yes
we should pay attention to that exactly
we should take pause and think about it
correct so
a lot of these republicans are saying
they're worried that
and this is so stupid that democrats
would assassinate trump like i that's
absurd we all agree that that just isn't
going to happen
however
what is the likeliness of an attempt not
a successful one mind you i'm pretty
confident the secret service would stop
it yeah but an attempt on his life from
a conservative because of the mar-a-lago
raids and these ideas that he might have
dirt on them sort of like an epstein
scenario whether he did or did not get
assassinated i won't get into that but
if that is the case like do you think
that is something that could happen to
trump so
in the next segment
in the email segment today
two people right in with a very similar
idea to what you're saying right now
um i i actually think that from a motive
standpoint it kind of does pass the
sniff test the idea of being like hey
let's talk about the left or deep state
or whatever planning to kill trump but
really we're the ones who want to kill
him to get him out of the way so we can
take back the republican party totally
plausible i mean really totally
plausible i just don't think they're
that organized quite frankly so so i
don't i don't actually expect anybody
from the right to try to kill trump
oh yeah no i don't think it would be an
organized thing i think it would just be
like one billionaire trying to do it or
something like that i mean listen if
we're talking about something completely
unorganized and random that of course
that could happen there any there could
always be some assassination attempt
sure but i mean it's not really the type
of thing we can predict in any serious
way
yeah and i i don't think it would ever
happen uh can i ask you one quick uh
non-political question i would be honest
yeah so i i know you live in the new
york general region i won't get into
specifics but when it comes to
um food outside of new york what do you
think is like the one food that once you
leave new york you can't get it anywhere
else
once you leave new york you can't get it
anywhere else you won't be able to find
as good of food
to give you an example i think of
everyone talks about pizza but i really
think it's bagels you can't get a good
bagel outside of new york in my opinion
i don't know about that i i have so
first of all i was just in montreal
quebec canada it's not the same thing
montreal bagels are their own thing but
i believe that they are just as good as
new york bagels it's just a different
style and to be perfectly frank i mean
there's a lot of places where you can't
get good bagels like once i was in
indiana and i tried getting a bagel and
it was like it should have been illegal
what i was handed um but but like in you
know in la there's plenty of good bagels
i don't know but i i do agree with you
that like
other than a few places
new york is the bagel place for sure
yeah i'm in ohio right now i live in new
york that's why i have the long island
tag but i'm visiting some family in ohio
and we had to bring them bagels because
they just don't have them here yeah you
know a crazy story um when uh when in in
college
my girlfriend did a study abroad in
spain and this was you know years ago
and there were no bagels anywhere in
madrid except one place started getting
bagels and so she goes she's like wow
this is great i'm you know if i'm from
the northeast of the us i'll be able to
get a bagel she goes and asks for a
bagel can i have cream cheese on it oh
no no cream cheese what what's that we
can we can put mayo on it so but they
they thought that the application for a
bagel was just a smear of mayonnaise if
you can imagine oh oh god that sounds
awful i don't like mayonnaise to begin
with yeah and just as a spread i mean
come on on a sandwich it's one thing but
yeah yeah if it's an additive okay but
as its main course
yep no we're on the same page my friend
all right thank you for the call i'll
let you get to other people i appreciate
it thank you very much uh very very uh
questions of critical importance i would
say for sure let's go next to kevin from
san diego kevin welcome
hey david how's it going it's going well
i was not expecting to call me i was
like busy with playing video games all
right well um yeah so
um i guess i'm still
i'm still wondering like what is uh what
is going to happen with this this trump
execution of a search warrant because it
was not actually a raid um
is uh
have we have we found anything more out
about uh what's going on with that
in what sense find out more and what do
you mean like is are there going to be
charges that type of thing well i mean
the latest thing that i heard was that
there was um trump was looking after
getting the uh what was it the affidavit
yeah
it released to everyone um which i think
pat was saying on like monday or
something you know that could backfire
on on trump if
that's something but we don't really
know what's in that affidavit yet um
yeah i don't know i'm just
i'm wondering
how how all of that's going to how
that's going to shake out if uh
listen we don't know yet there's a
couple different things that might
happen if it sort of evaporates and
nothing happens and there's no charges
and it just kind of fades the narrative
from the right will be this was
unnecessary and outrageous and meant to
humiliate trump and they will have a
case that that case will feel very
strong if that's the case because this
is a big step to take it was a
completely legal step they they crossed
all the eyes and dotted all the t's as
sean hannity said um but
if if nothing happens to do this to a
president is a big step so that's one
possibility and that will probably
strengthen the right beyond that there's
a number of other possible scenarios
whose timing you know is it before after
the midterms is it before after trump
potentially declares his candidacy for
24 there's just too many unknowns right
now to say
yeah
i mean i am really i i want it to be
something where i see having like the
affidavit get released but like redacted
any kind of people's names that uh
would be
uh
potentially targets of right-wing
extreme people going after them uh that
i think that would be good because
having something that like sort of
proves like yeah trump does have
somebody that's in his organization that
basically sold him out and
told them that there was uh there was
all these documents that were that would
be i think the potentially most damaging
thing that could come from the affidavit
which is the confirmation that there is
a sort of mole or traitor which has been
speculated but not proven
yeah but then again that also comes with
the the downside of
if the mole or traitor is revealed but
it's not redacted then like that
person's going to be everybody's going
to go be going after them like yeah
they're going after bruce wayne and the
dark knight returns which i don't want i
want people to be safe so yeah yeah that
would be bad uh well let's give it
another couple weeks and see where we
are you know around
mid-september yeah censor all right
thank you for the call very much
appreciated we're going to take the
quickest of breaks but don't hang up
because then we're going right back to
the discord lines and we're going to
hear from more people so just stand by
we will be right back with more of your
calls
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show let's get back to the
phones and by phones i don't really mean
phones i mean discord because we use
discord now and we are going to hear
from some people uh just as a reminder
to everybody who's waiting in the
waiting lobby if you have a nickname
if you have you know some kind of joke
or whatever the case may be i will not
be going to you so it's totally fine to
have your nickname or whatever i see
people with all sorts of nicknames uh
you're just your name has to be in the
format of your name and where you're
calling from in order to be eligible to
get on with me today along those lines
let's go to sam from minnesota sam thank
you for
sticking to the rules with your nickname
oh yeah how's my volume your volume's
pretty pretty okay yeah
all right so
uh i guess one
just a minnesota question uh we've we've
uh been on top of the
voting turnout for quite a while i think
the last
five six seven
no i think maine beat us back in 2010
anyway so we have had the best turnout
do you think that'll
if turnout continues to skyrocket do you
think we'll stay on top or do you think
we might lose out to somebody you know
that's a very interesting question uh
you know i didn't know
but you were right it looks like the top
turnout in the u.s
in 2022
now what does this include i guess this
must be primaries it's minnesota
new jersey
and oregon is that does that sound right
to you the top turnout states very very
interesting uh i didn't know new jersey
was so high the last general in 2020 uh
maine was second place but new jersey
yeah new jersey would be really
skyrocketing if they were number two
because they were
you know what i'm seeing i'm seeing new
jersey's number one at 85 percent and
minnesota's number two at 83 percent can
you believe it
wow if new jersey's in the 80s that's
pretty crazy yeah they must have some
really determined primary goers yeah so
uh you basically now that i have the
data in front of me what was your
question
or just uh in the general do you think
minnesota will stay on top or do you
think it's gonna be in jew jersey
i have no idea i mean listen i don't
know the dynamics of the
you've got like primary and in general i
think that all of these states are going
to be high
um
part of it is the relationship between
what is the process to register to vote
versus
how likely are you to go and vote so
there's this i my instinct is there's
this kind of reverse uh
mechanism where
if it's harder to register to vote which
i'm against right i think it should be
really easy to register but if it's
harder to register
your turnout as a share of registered
voters might end up being higher because
there's sort of like more obstacles to
get registered so you're probably more
enthusiastic about voting
so i don't know enough about voter
registration process in new jersey
minnesota mississippi oregon which are
the top four turnout states i think
we're just basically guessing and we
have to wait and see
yeah i i think um i'm not so sure about
automatic registration but like same day
registration where you walk in to vote
and you're like oh i'm not registered
well let me just register then yeah it's
it's incomprehensible to me that anybody
doesn't do that minnesota does and we've
done it since the 70s and right
beautiful
well congratulations to minnesota for
voting and we'll see what things look
like in the fall
yeah thanks all right thank you for the
call very much appreciate it
let's keep talking to people because i
don't know there are people who want to
talk and it seems like
it's a great thing
let's go to guillaume from montreal uh
guillaume i had a beautiful time there
last week
oh hi david uh well glad to hear you had
a beautiful beautiful time
and you know what it was when you came
over i mean i i did not go out all that
much i was pretty much uh secluded at
home it was insanely hot actually and
you know what i told the story uh or i'm
going to tell the story on today's bonus
show i was recognized on the street more
in montreal than anywhere else that i
have ever been i was only there six days
and 12 people came up to me to say they
watched the show
nice nice i mean to be fair most of us
use your show the young turks and david
pakman
not david pacman uh fair and cousins my
bad okay
yeah as a great way to stay informed on
what's happening all the way over there
beautiful
country usa
that's fantastic well what was on your
mind today
uh well first and foremost uh just
pointing out that when i when we talked
last time my friends uh really liked
your idea of uh
uh trying to tackle the campaign finance
whole constitutional amendment good
and my actual big question right now is
a lot more
static it's a lot less hypothetical it's
a question of what do you feel about
calling the current era of politics
worldwide not just in the u.s
an era of um
uh what could i say um
i'm looking for the word here at
um
not oh yeah there you go there we go
glory politics so it's all about getting
your name on something it's all about
getting your name to be recognized as
the name that did something good
i don't think that that's unique to this
era i mean for me there are other things
that strike me as unique to this era
including
the high percentage of people engaged in
politics who quite literally have no
idea what's going on and understand
nothing about anything like the fact
that that's a movement and it's a
movement that has pride we don't know a
damn thing about anything and we vote
and you've got to deal with us haha
that seems much more unique to this era
you know the the glory politics stuff if
we want
bridges and and all these different
things named after us i feel like that's
been going on
at least since the 50s in the united
states i get what you get what you're
getting at but i'm more thinking about
before it's been built i want my name on
it
i mean we all know that obamacare was
essentially
dubbed obamacare
after it was passed because it was more
convenient than saying an affordable
care act every single time you wanted to
say it
yeah i mean it listen i i don't think
you're wrong that this exists it doesn't
strike me as the most notable thing
about the era i'll put it that way
no that's that's perfectly fine yeah on
that lovely note have a great day and
thank you for taking my call guillaume
real quick are you a saint viator bagel
guy or a fairmont bagel guy
um
that's a great question
uh
i'll have to say signed via
wow that's a big declaration from you
it's mostly because every single time i
have a bagel that's the most
available to me where i am oh okay so
it's a convenience thing
and
i've never had a single problem with it
so it's a recognizable brand for me it's
a it's a literal
i know this is good enough for me i
don't need to go test further unless
that's unavailable hey if it ain't broke
don't fix it i like that guillaume
i mean don't get me wrong if you if you
serve me any other bagel i'll take it
and probably enjoy it just as much as as
long as it's of decent quality just
don't get
don't get me to try and choose another
than that one i'm with you all right my
friend thank you for the call
thank you and have a great day all right
there's guillaume from montreal let's go
next to
uh well where are we going to go next
because we really have quite a situation
happening on the phone lines let's go to
grant from ohio grant welcome
thank you david
for taking my call my pleasure uh
hey
and grant we we've you've got to turn
off those discord blings you've got to
do do not disturb turn off notifications
you know whatever it is that needs to be
done we got to do it
all right sorry no
um
well hey i was wondering
if there was any updates with the map
gates um
a criminal investigation with possibly
sex trafficking i know it's been going
on for quite some time
i just saw a story this morning and i
just didn't have time to um
look at it in detail
it's a daily beast story from yesterday
actually which is called eight sources
say the feds are not done with matt
gates and these eight sources told the
daily beast that the investigation is
still very much alive and that matt
gates is not out of the woods that's
this article you know and that's the
eight sources that they have i don't
know any more than that but that's you
know 12 hours old at this point so i
think that's the newest info
yeah i just saw an nbc poll or it says
he's going to win his district again oh
of course
and i think it also said that district's
been read since
at least 30 years ago
it's been a long time it's oh he's
absolutely going to win yeah i know i i
think
listen what we know is he's a horrible
person he may have committed crimes and
there's currently a very serious
investigation into that
yeah it's just kind of yeah kind of sad
um and then
another
i don't know if this would be a personal
and also um
professional question do you ever plan
on writing any books um about i don't
know about anything or politics yeah i'm
sort of working on a proposal now and i
have so many things going on that that
it's tough to finish it and move on to
the next step but i am in the middle of
a proposal and as soon as i have
something to announce on a book i will
all right well thank you so much for
taking my call my pleasure grant thank
you uh uh there is grant from uh ohio
very very respectful in every way which
we love
let's go to timothy from miami now
timothy are you in miami or miami beach
i am just in miami okay that's fine
that's okay
that's allowed
oh sorry um
i
i'm sorry let me
turn down my microphone here um
is there a way for you to turn me down
or do i have to do it myself
no you're you're everything's fine what
was on your mind today
oh well uh i just want to say i wanted
to bring up a good point that hopefully
you could tell to other people sure but
uh the thing is so i i've noticed that
the republicans and the whole idea of
the trump of trump
winning the 2020 election and
writing the lie that he did the big lie
uh is kind of like our modern day
version of the lost cosmetic from the
civil war do you understand what i mean
no not at all
well
it's the sense that conservatives are
once again lying about something you
know with the lost cause narrative it's
the idea that the civil war was not
about
slavery it was about states rights you
know what i mean it all revolves around
a lie where today it's donald trump
didn't lose the 2020 election joe biden
stole it you understand what i mean in
that sense you know i kind of do yeah
the the lost cause of the confederacy is
the general narrative that really the
motivation for
um the confederacy was to preserve
states rights in principle and it just
so happened that that would also allow
slavery to remain legal but that really
wasn't what they wanted it wasn't about
slavery i i just don't know that i'm
understanding how that is equivalent to
the big lie
you're just saying it was a lie that
that's what the confederacy was about
and it's a lie that trump won both are
just lies
i mean i guess it's also that
it and that and also in the fact that
it's also being peddled by once again
these extremist conservatives that you
know have not really gone away and you
know
it it it just seems there's just
something about both situations that
seem because you know a lot of time in
american politics a lot of the
situations that we're suffering from
today are often the same issues or often
rehashed issues
from generations ago you know oh well so
i don't know if this is exactly what you
mean and i apologize if we're having
trouble understanding each other but one
of the things that that you're saying
that is actually resonating a lot is
we're talking now so long after the
civil war and yet you still hear certain
political partisans repeat this thing it
wasn't about slavery for us it wasn't
about slavery for the confederacy
could the big lie become that we're even
a hundred years from now you still
continue to have people saying you know
trump really did win in 2020. that you
know that seems possible
i i was going to say that you know
southern you know southern people have
you know engraved this into the minds of
their children and to their
grandchildren and i believe it's very
possible they also could have tried to
change southern history you know
propaganda films stuff like that i got
death of a nation yeah it's very
possible these extreme trumpets
conservatives that are somehow even more
extreme well try to do something to put
into people's minds that trump really
did not uh lose and if 2024
does not go for trump uh we could be
seeing some
catastrophic violations of history
freedom of speech do you understand what
i mean i do very much so i do very much
so uh it's kind of like the same effect
and i'm it's just something
about it that i just can't get out of my
head
well you've said it beautifully and i
share your concern and let's monitor and
see what happens
thank you so much david i'm a huge fan
of the show last time i was on your call
it didn't really go well it was during
uh buying state of the union address
okay well i'm glad we were able to
communicate today there's timothy from
miami and on that note we're going to go
to a break we will take calls again soon
and when we do
i hope to be able to speak to you
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right let's get into this week's
mailbag info davidpakman.com is the
place to email if you have something to
say sometimes we'll take a youtube
comment or a tweet reply or a facebook
message or whatever starting today in
fact indeed with a facebook message from
gianni who said you look like a soy jack
in real life effing loser now this was a
new one i i recently asked on my twitter
what does it mean to be cuck-pilled i
not a term i'd heard before last week
and it was unclear what it meant i also
didn't know what a soy jack is so i
looked this one up this one apparently
is a meme
which is often used in online discourse
where you post a soy jack which i guess
is an image um and the idea is when you
post it you're saying the person you're
arguing online with is a betta soy boy
so that's that and apparently i am a soy
jack in real life maybe not on the
internet but in real life i am a soy
jack so very very important messaging
there
brandon wrote in about a potential biden
pardon of trump
and brandon says
david long time listener first time
question
wondering if you could unpack the
hypothetical scenario of biden pardoning
trump in an effort to bring the country
together to avoid the inevitable
political and cultural turmoil of such a
process thank you for your level-headed
perspective you know i don't think it's
completely out of the realm of
possibility that if the next few months
or the next year for trump go in a
particular way and i would call it going
south for lack of a better term
i actually don't think it's completely
impossible
that biden would consider such a pardon
again to unite the country sort of in
the way that it happened with nixon
but my hope is that he wouldn't do that
because at some point we have to be
if no one is above the law
it means not only that anybody can be
charged but it has to mean that people
actually have to have consequences for
the things that they do if they are
found guilty of doing those things so
i do think brandon's instinct is right
that biden does seem like the type of
guy
who would go above partisanship
and in certain scenarios might say i i'm
going to pardon donald trump we're
thinking many steps ahead
but i hope that it doesn't happen
because i do think that we really need
to put our money where our mouths are
when it comes to individuals not being
above the law and that means when
there's a consequence you don't get out
of it because you used to be the
president
greg wrote in about this deep state
assassination plot theory we've heard
from right-wingers like
um steve bannon
and rudy giuliani and others over the
last few weeks that the mar-a-lago raid
might be the first step by the deep
state to eventually assassinate donald
trump and it sounds crazy greg says
here's my theory
regarding the deep state assassination
attempt you're always saying that when
the right is accusing
they're usually the ones guilty
i believe they're floating it out there
for one of their own to assassinate
trump so that they can make a martyr out
of him in hopes to push their agenda
further and also make the democrats look
terrible what are your thoughts thanks
love the show right that's an
interesting idea and in fact there could
be two layers
let's just think about motive just
because it's fun even if we don't think
this is really what's going on
if you are
a republican and you're worried that
trump is really terrible for your
movement
you could say hey you know what's
perfect
let's get trump killed
because then one we get him out of the
way
and two
we can run on the left killed him and
it'll just be great for us we can have a
non-trump candidate energized by this
alleged assassination of trump by the
deep state or by the left or whatever
certainly a beautiful beautiful uh idea
i don't think that that is what they are
planning
in this particular case but if you
disagree certainly let me know because
it's it's an interesting one keith also
wrote to me about the trump
assassination
and trump and keith says david what
group has brought up assassination
the far right
trump is cooked he's going to be a bad
package as investigations continue it is
not the democrats or some nutty deep
state it will be the republicans getting
traction and political support as
republicans take him out the republican
leadership are done with him and want to
take control of their party again make
trump a martyr cause a total political
uproar
bannon will take him out well listen if
the right wants to kill trump i don't
think it's going to be bannon
uh but
keith with a similar idea there for sure
and again i get the motive truly the
motive actually does make a lot of sense
but um i don't actually think that
that's what's going on
austin has sort of gotten to the end of
his rope
austin wrote in and says if herschel
walker wins
i'm out
david sir this is a roy well okay the
email says it's austin but then says
it's roy this is roy from south jersey
as we know herschel walker is a disgrace
a joke and cannot speak
but this crossed the line
his ex-wife aired a commercial where she
described him choking beating and
pointing a gun at her on multiple
occasions walker's response
went quote when they attacking me that
means they are scared of me they know
i'm going to be the one to win that seat
because they gotta come out and try to
attack me continue to bring up things
that is really helping me i wanted them
i'm glad they brought up the attack with
my ex-wife this is uh done a long time
ago it was done to help people because
that uh commercial there only tells
people i'm gonna continue to be a
warrior
i'm gonna continue to fight for mental
health
him beating his wife was done to help
other people
if he wins i'm moving i don't know where
but i cannot live in a country where one
of 100 senators is this mentally
challenged and or evil
i don't know that i would use all the
exact same words that austin
roy is using here
but
there is a certain despondency
that i completely identify with
if this guy can win despite being unable
to even put together a coherent sentence
over the
intelligent and well-versed and
politically knowledgeable raphael
warnock
it would be such a humiliation for
everything we know
of our country
and listen i'm not threatening to move
but it would be really really bad
brian wrote in about bo hines and says
david did you see the bo hines interview
he's a trump endorsed former college
football player that's running for
congress in north carolina he thinks
when people are calling the us a banana
republic they're referring to the
clothing store
the republican party is
indistinguishable from an snl skit or an
onion article brian from minnesota i did
see that it's a wild clip i don't have
it pulled up here
but you can easily find it if you google
bohein's banana republic
he talks about
like it when he mentions oh they're
calling us a banana republic he talks
about the manager of a banana republic
store like he completely doesn't get
that banana republic is a pejorative for
countries
whose you know the the idea is that
they've gotten advanced enough
to produce bananas
and it's a pejorative and it's not a
term that i tend to use quite frankly
uh keith wrote in and says conservatives
aren't a fraction of the population
especially when considering that
demographics show that as of 2021
23 of americans age 18 to 29 are
considered conservative compared to 45
percent of american 65 plus
likewise 34 percent of americans 18 to
29 are liberal compared to 21 percent of
american 65 plus compare the
conservative and liberal stats and that
would be 68 demographic majority
compared to a 55 liberal minority hardly
a fraction of the population of
conservatives as you falsely stated it
also wasn't a fraction of the population
that got trump elected into office a
gallup poll as recently as 2019 showed
conservatives outnumber liberals 25
states and highly in 19 states based on
all of that you have no idea what you're
talking about so this no keith i'm sorry
you have no idea what i'm talking about
so there's two things here and all of
this word salad doesn't address it
number one
when you talk to people
about their views on issues you quickly
realize that the country is as left as
it has been since polling has existed
you ask about
should the government provide a basic
level of health care to everybody even
if they can't pay
okay you look at the answers on that you
ask people should the government tax the
very rich in order to help the very poor
have a basic standard of living you ask
about whether abortion should be legal
in most cases you ask about gay marriage
you ask about is climate change real
when you talk to people about issues you
find an electorate that is as left as it
has been in the modern political era
number two
it really is a minority that got trump
elected into office only about half the
country votes
and less
than half of those who voted voted for
trump right hillary got more votes and
biden got more votes okay so it is
literally a minority of the country that
got trump elected
so
the polls you're talking about are how
do people self-identify i know tons of
people that say i'm a conservative and
then i ask them their views on issues
and they're liberal on every issue so it
is you that is confused keith and i
would encourage you to you know maybe
read up a little bit
jasic wrote in
and says david sir you've already
addressed several times the
conservatives response to all criticism
of hershel walker's inability to
vocalize his thoughts on any subject but
i can't recall you emphasizing the
context he's running for senate which
requires intellectual capacity the
definition of discrimination is unjust
or prejudicial treatment so it is not
discriminatory to expect a person making
the most consequential decisions for the
entire country to make some sense yeah
that's a fair point
often when i and others criticize
herschel walker for being unable to
express his political positions on any
issue for being unable to speak
coherently for just mumbling word salads
that don't make any sense some of the
reaction will be oh you know you're
you're discriminating against people who
maybe lack education or lack cognitive
capacity or have mental illness or have
chronic traumatic encephalopathy or
whatever
no what i'm saying is it we have a
hundred senators
and they should be able to think clearly
and express themselves coherently and so
walker doesn't meet the requirements and
of course the
in a literal sense the requirements are
to be a citizen and to be the right age
but and to live in the state in which
you're running
what we would all as a collective
society i think agree on is we should
have smart people who can understand
issues and explain themselves and speak
um
it is not discriminatory in the sense
that he doesn't meet those
fundamental basics and i think jasic is
completely correct
um paul wrote in about electric cars
and he does not like my recent defenses
of electric cars saying cars are the
most dangerous
inefficient
expensive and environmentally and
socially harmful means of transportation
available
electric cars reduce one of those
problems carbon emissions although with
some offsetting costs in terms of mining
if you really want to address the
climate disaster you need to focus on a
host of reforms which will reduce or
eliminate our dependency on cars as our
primary means of transportation listen
i'm right there with you there is no
greater advocate than me for better
public transit this means both within
and between cities
our uh
national rail is a complete and total
joke
we um in many cities public transit is a
joke
i would much rather a future
in which vehicles are
sort of on demand
and driverless so that listen for most
of us our cars sit in a driveway
on the street or in a garage
90 of the time or more of the day right
most people the you most people aren't
driving two and a half hours a day which
is like 10 percent of the day
um so my preference would be
dramatically reduce the number of
vehicles have an on-demand system
where when you actually need a vehicle
it shows up gets you where you need to
go and then brings other people around
the the reforms we need are dramatic
dramatic and yes obviously just public
transit is great the reality in the
united states when there are so many
suburban and rural areas is it seems
more likely to me that on demand
autonomous electric vehicles
are going to be
a better fit for parts of the country
than like bus high-capacity buses where
you just don't have the number of people
needing these particular uh roots
uh to justify it financially in much of
the country that is the perfect solution
so listen i'm with paul uh but when it
comes to electric vehicles versus
internal combustion engines i am on the
side of electric vehicles
info at davidpakman.com questions
comments whatever
let me know info davidpakman.com and of
course make sure that you are signed up
at
joinpacman.com so that you get instant
access to the bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad
hard to make
a better case for the bonus show than
that
join pacman.com we will see you then oh
today
on the bonus show i will tell the story
of my first visit to a starbucks in 20
years it happened earlier this week how
did it happen
and what happened i will tell you
you